[Music]
ravelin is a fraud detection company we
specialize in detecting credit card
fraud when a customer tries to buy
something from one of our merchants the
merchant will then stream as all of that
data and we will use a load of machine
learning behind the scenes to try and
analyze transaction and make predictions
around whether that user is a genuine
user or a fraudulent user security is
really important for us because our
clients are trusting us with all of
their data so we go to extraordinary
lengths to ensure that the data that we
hold is encrypted and secure than close
source projects so on Prem has the
problem of having to manage your own
security the actual cloud itself and the
way the Google structures the file
system means that one file isn't stored
on one computer it's stored across
multiple disks which means even if
someone was able to get access to a
particular disc of physical access they
wouldn't actually be able to get any
data from that there's a number of
services that GCP offered we couldn't
get elsewhere like the identity of a
proxy and encryption arrest by default
but also the further step that enables
us to supply encryption keys to Google
so the Google can't even unencrypted the
data if they wanted to so those are all
really strong factors that suggest that
Google really cares about security and
it enables us to trust Google with all
of our data
[Music]